- [Narrator] Let's say you wanted
to buy this Primark T-shirt.
If you're shopping on Primark's website,
you'll quickly discover that you can't.
(buzzer dings)
Over the past 10 years,
e-commerce sales have more than doubled.
But last year,
European fast fashion retailer
Primark made 9.5 billion
in sales revenue without a single penny
from online shopping.
- We made a very clear choice
and our clear choice is bricks and mortar.
- [Narrator] This comes
at an uncertain time
for struggling clothing retailers.
Retailers like Forever 21, JC Penney,
and Neiman Marcus have closed stores
and filed for bankruptcy.
And while a UBS report shows
up to 80,000 retail stores
will close in the next five years,
Primark plans to expand to 60
stores in the same timeframe.
- [Speaker] Is driving
two hours from Toronto
to Buffalo to shop at Primark worth it?
Heck yes, I used to
fly six hours to do so.
- So how is Primark expanding
without online shopping?
This is the economics of Primark.
- Fashion retail is
incredibly competitive,
more so than ever.
There's not many players,
especially in fast fashion
that are making fat margins.
Pretty much the thinking everywhere is
that you have to have
this online presence.
- [Narrator] But online shopping is
actually incredibly
expensive for retailers.
- You have to have a logistical hub
from which you would dispatch the goods
and then you'd probably have
a local distribution center
from which you have to
do last mile delivery.
Each step of that just is
an extra layer of cost,
it just eats away at the margin at which
in fashion is very, very slim
anyway, but the real killer
for e-commerce is somebody
who buys something
on the internet is far more
likely to return that product
than somebody who goes into a store.
- [Narrator] Returns are one
of the biggest profit
losses for online retailers.
On average, processing
a return for $100 worth
of merchandise bought online
costs a company 26.50.
For years, online retailers
just ate these expenses.
Only now are more
of them deciding to pass the
cost back to the consumer.
- Primark have just stayed
right from the beginning,
we don't think we can make
money out of e-commerce.
We're not even gonna try.
We're gonna focus all our resources
on the physical store
and protect our margins.
- [Narrator] And that wasn't an issue
for the retailer until.
- Now Primark is expected to close all 189
of its UK stores tonight
and it doesn't have an online
offering to fall back on.
- E-commerce was a lifeline
for a lot of retailers
during the pandemic.
They couldn't open their
stores, but they were still able
to make some sales on the internet.
- [Narrator] But Primark didn't budge,
even as consumers urged
for it to offer online shopping and even
after its revenue dropped
by almost 2 billion pounds.
- And I think their
confidence in this model
of having no digital sales
and only using stores I think,
was probably shaken by the pandemic.
Who knows what would've happened
if it had gone on for longer?
I think the closures
weren't quite long enough
to really tip the scales
and force them to fundamentally
rethink the model.
- [Narrator] Instead of
traditional online shopping,
in 2022, Primark launched
a trial service called,
Click and Collect in select UK stores.
Customers can select
certain products online,
then pick up their orders in store.
So Primark still has some
cost to maintain its website
but it's cheaper than
running a true online shop.
- So Primark makes a sale,
but they don't have any
of the logistical costs
that would be involved
in packing it up and then
shipping it out to your home.
- [Narrator] And there's
another bonus for Primark.
Since the customer has to go inside
to collect their purchase,
they're likely to browse around
and maybe even buy more.
- They make the sale online,
but then they have a good chance
of making some extra sales
when that person visits them.
- [Narrator] Consumer psychologists
call this shopping momentum.
Essentially, once you've already
decided to make a purchase,
it's easier to justify
adding more to your cart.
- It always feels just overwhelmingly busy
with people who are in
there looking for bargains.
- [Narrator] And it's not just clothing.
Primark lures consumers with beauty, home,
and travel products similar
to a department store.
- What we like to say about
Primark here in the US is
that we're all treasure without the hunt.
- [Narrator] So customers may go in
for a new t-shirt and
leave with a suitcase.
- [Speaker] Primark that I
can drive to and don't have
to fly to is a dream because
that means there's no limit
to what I can buy and bring home.
- [Narrator] To carry this
vast selection of items,
Primark finds large retail spaces
because it relies on selling a lot.
It's one of the largest
retailers in the UK
by volume and one of the
largest across all of Europe.
Last year, Primark made about
9.5 billion in sales revenue
in part by selling a lot of
things at low profit margins.
And it does this by sourcing a lot
of its clothing from Asia.
Combined with not
offering online shopping,
this enables Primark
to sell its merchandise
at lower prices,
even lower than many other
fast fashion retailers.
- Where they do have
serious rivals on price is
with the digital only players
that like Shein for example,
they are often even cheaper than Primark.
- [Narrator] But according
to The National Retail Federation,
80% of shopping still happens in store,
giving Primark an edge
over its digital only
competitors, even so,
its in-store shopping model got off
to a rocky start in the US.
Primark opened its first US
store in Boston back in 2015.
Although it was already popular in the UK,
its US expansion started slowly.
Over four years, it opened nine stores.
After years of experimentation,
Primark learned it would have to change
to succeed in the US.
- When we first opened,
we took a similar store size
that we would've had in Europe.
- [Narrator] But when
Primark opened its stores
across the northeast,
it struggled to find
the right store density.
- What they found in
the US is that retail is
so much more competitive.
There's a lot more retail
in downtown areas in the US
than there is in the UK, for example.
So you just can't support a massive store.
It's just not possible to get
enough revenue for the size.
- To support its large store sizes,
it needed a lot of foot traffic.
But unlike the UK stores
which were located
in constantly busy areas, US
stores were mostly in malls
where during the week,
foot traffic dwindled.
- We learned that actually,
35,000 square foot
of retail selling space is
actually the sweet spot for us.
- They didn't face the commercial pressure
that a publicly owned
company might have faced
to suddenly open 100 stores
and get really big really quickly
and then possibly risk disaster
because they hadn't thought it through.
- The culture of Primark has always been
to take our time and to test and learn.
And we've done that in every country
where we've introduced the brand.
This wasn't about growing
market share at all costs.
- [Narrator] And the overall
retail market is shifting.
Online shopping hit a peak
during Covid, but now,
growth is beginning to slow
as people return to stores.
- And I think that's
never been so important
as it is since we came outta Covid.
I think there has been
a massive rediscovery
of being in malls, being
together, physical shopping,
and I think as a business
that took the decision a long time ago
to have that as our core strategy,
has continued to allow
us to be successful.
(upbeat music)